this week on brian ross investigates
trouble on the diamond decision time for
one of baseball's star pitchers accused
of domestic violence last july bower was
placed on administrative leave after a
san diego woman claimed he sexually
assaulted her at his pasadena home but
trevor bauer denies any wrongdoing while
we did have consensual rough sex the
disturbing acts and conduct that she
described simply did
not occur
he's not been charged with any crime but
will major league baseball enforce its
zero tolerance policy on domestic abuse
plus an investigation into how america's
billionaires bloomberg bezos and others
gained the taxes
the thing that really struck us
was that how little they pay
particularly when you compare
how much they're worth
and what about those hidden tax breaks
for the super rich owners of sports
teams this is a magical place where
sports team owners can tell the
government they make tens or even
hundreds of millions less than they
actually do and pay very little in taxes
and it's all perfectly legal
reporters expose the facts reveal the
documents and send the message if you're
getting a w-2 you're a sucker
and this week's winners and losers in
the media see if you agree with the
choices made by the editors of mediaite
they happen to have they have not
monetized 500 million viewers i mean
what are they thinking
from the studios of the law and crime
trial network in new york city's herald
square
this is brian ross investigates
good evening and welcome i'm brian ross
joined as always by my colleague rhonda
schwartz and ronda we begin with trouble
on the diamond over domestic violence
allegations the country's been watching
allegations of domestic violence being
leveled back and forth in a virginia
courtroom between actor johnny depp and
his ex-wife but there's another
high-profile domestic violence case that
is heading for a showdown a case
involving baseball star trevor bauer the
los angeles dodgers pitchers who's been
kept off the field since last june even
as he continues to collect his 28
million dollar a year salary ronda major
league baseball has yet to say how or
even if he will be punished
that's right brian bauer was placed on
administrative leave after a 27 year old
woman alleged that bauer had punched her
choked her into unconsciousness and had
anal sex with her while she was passed
out trevor says it was all consensual
and authorities in california have
declined to prosecute him leaving
baseball to decide what comes next
dodgers pitcher trevor bauer will not
face any criminal charges following
accusations of sexual assault last july
bower was placed on administrative leave
after a san diego woman claimed he
sexually assaulted her at his pasadena
home last june a 27-year-old woman he
met on social media testified the sexual
encounters between them turned violent
today l.a county prosecutors say they
cannot prove her case beyond a
reasonable doubt
i never punch this woman in the face
i never punched her in the vagina i
never scratched her face i never had
anal sex with her or sodomized her in
any way
i never assaulted her in any way at any
time and while we did have consensual
rough sex the disturbing acts and
conduct that she described simply did
not occur
so now to help us get a better
understanding of how baseball and
professional sports in general are
dealing with this issue of domestic
violence we're joined by jay risinger
attorney in pittsburgh who's represented
a number of athletes facing similar
allegations including in the past trevor
bauer and jay i know you're not
representing bauer in this case let me
ask you this if prosecutors say there's
not enough evidence to bring charges
what options does the mlb have
the joint domestic violence program
between major league baseball
and the major league baseball players
association sets out very clearly it
actually in its preamble
that criminal charges aren't required um
in order to find the necessary um
aspects of domestic violence with
respect to the policy put it shortly
a crime is not required for the
commissioner to determine that there's
been a violation of the policy
so is that fair to a player like trevor
bauer who denies it as you saw so
forthrightly
whether it's fair or not
um
no it's not fair it's it it's not fair
um
but
it is a a policy that the players
association and major league baseball
agreed to and and thus he's
required to abide by it uh jay a
question for you from ronda schwartz
rhonda
jay in this situation
trevor's denied all these allegations
but for major league ballplayers for
other professional sports athletes who
are accused with these kinds of
accusations
since they are such role models
shouldn't they be held to a higher
standard
regardless
um
not in my opinion i don't think there
should be a higher standard applied to
professional athletes at all no
jay i know you're not involved in this
case directly but what do you think is
taking a major league baseball so long
they continue to extend this
administrative leave why can't they
decide what to do
well
first of all i think they were waiting
for
the results of of
the criminal investigation
you know beyond that um i i mean this is
the most complicated domestic violence
case of the entire
um
you know dv policy time frame which is
i believe from 2016 to the president
it takes a long time
major league baseball does their own
internal investigations
they have
former prosecutors
uh on staff that are looking into it
so it takes a while
in this case major league baseball says
it is still investigating the
allegations if they come down hard on
trevor bauer does he have an appeal
process what happens next for him or
does he have to take it
no he does not have to take it he has
the right to appeal to an independent
arbitrator which would be the system
arbitrator
um
that
that's prescribed by by the cba
and
certainly if a suspension
of of some length is imposed he's
certainly going to appeal
and jay finally let me ask you is the
get tough stance taken by major league
baseball and other professional sports
leagues is it working is it reducing the
amount of domestic violence involving
these players
that's a great question i think the
answer is no
i think domestic violence it's an
important issue for for everybody to pay
attention to
but but i'm not sure that the rules that
are in place
i i don't think it changes
whether whether domestic violence occurs
or not i i really don't
all right well jay risen i want to thank
you so much for joining us tonight and
for your valuable insights
thank you
up next for most americans this has been
the week to settle with the irs but not
for america's super rich we'll find out
why you're watching brian ross
investigates on the law and crime trial
network